I have a real butt I have a real butt I
have a real butt I have a real butt I
have a real butt
hi okay well what does everyone do first
of all I'm a personal trainer personal
trainer Bartender Bartender from school
for Real Estate so wow okay how about
you I'm a property manager model and
also bartender okay
recruiter social media coordinator okay
okay I'm a content creator so okay okay
interesting when she mentioned that she
was a content creator that immediately
gave me red flags I feel like just in
this day and age like a lot of content
creators or even like Fitness
influencers will get things done and
right now you know bbls are kind of in
so I was just suspicious of that so who
works out and what do you do I work out
like I can show y'all
so I'm like I am a personal trainer
guest but like I do work out oh my gosh
okay homegrown yeah I know I lost them
50 pounds I was a bigger girl so that's
just something I've experienced people
like what are your experiences with fake
butt like do people ever accuse you guys
yeah when I was smaller yeah for me I
store for Adidas so I would get all the
time really yeah because you have to
wear tights oh yeah yeah
just say like I go to the gym too I like
to lift weights so I feel like I don't
really get accused of like having a fake
button because you know they see me
doing this yeah
I also lift weights oh it's tight Queen
okay okay what do you guys do for like
growing the glutes so for Flag Day I do
squats I do hip thrusts I do hip rest a
lot I like the blue Bridges the ks blue
Bridges they will your glutes up
I'm so sorry I don't know if I can curve
I do a lot of Bulgarian squats oh yeah
oh my God don't kill me I just started
working out again
I used to almost be 300 pounds so I
started losing a lot of weight oh my God
so I've been hiking a lot I've been
going to the gym as much as I can and
you know just trying to eat healthy I
love that yeah I don't work out
it could be examined yeah
okay we just show our butt yeah like
show okay okay we have a skirt right
right nice
the fact that everyone was showing off
their butt and she wore a skirt that
covered it I was a little skeptical like
what's under there what are you hiding
what's your secret girl you're built so
different thank you
okay
[Laughter]
wow I literally have no idea guys
oh my God girl okay it's like blue
potatoes
[Applause]
I feel like we should go around and like
name like what we're insecure about our
butt or something we like about it I
guess I'm insecure about like you know
like the Shelf where like people have
that like oh my gosh so you know that's
why I try to work on I think it's an
easy thing and my butt looks better on
the side but like from the front I feel
like it doesn't look the best but I feel
like the hardest thing would just be
trying to find pants that fit good yeah
you know and skirts and dresses yeah but
for me I definitely feel like it's a
shelf and I think it's just an Asian
American thing it's just like how we're
built but yeah it's definitely like the
shelf and then like also like how my
butt is like kind of like Square shaped
I think but you know like we're able to
like point out our own insecurities
better than anybody else yeah I would
never have thought that I don't know
tips mostly and also just like but I do
like the side profile and I like the
feel I guess like it feels nice okay
when I was like growing I like ate a lot
of food and I got stretch marks on my
butt which is how it is but the shaping
that's definitely what I like about it
more than anything for me it was
cellulite because before I was like
super big and then I had to lose weight
then I got skinny then I had to build it
back up and like that's just something
that comes and goes still I feel like my
biggest insecurity is that I feel like I
don't have the hips that matches my butt
like because I am half asian American
and we have more narrow hips a little
bit of a hip dip situation going on but
I love my butt I feel like I don't
really have to work hard for it
hey have you spotted them all yet well
hang tight because we're gonna get there
until then subscribe to our Channel now
let's get back to the video
[Music]
she has the perfect booty like when you
think of a BBL she has exactly what you
would expect to see
I'm sorry
foreign
okay goodbye peace and love bye
um I'm kind of flattered that I got
eliminated first kind of makes me feel
good about myself not gonna lie all
right let's just get into it I feel
comfortable like touching each other yes
every day
at the same time
okay
this feels so weird okay
I'm feeling for like you know firmness
and like jiggle I guess usually when
people have like pbls they're like mad
defined like snatched
[Laughter]
funny I'm sorry
okay
Naya her butt felt a bit like firm but
she had mentioned that she had only
recently started working out and usually
when I feel like someone's butt is firm
it means more muscular so that made me
just a little suspicious of her all
right
okay okay
okay
yeah okay I know some of you guys work
out is it genetics do they play a role
on like having a big butt and if so yes
and how I've always just like kind of
had an ass like my entire life like yeah
I think it's just genetics you know
we're all like Asian American us three
and we can all relate to like you know
like the hip dips part like the square
and like you know not having an upper
booty oh I mean like if you were working
out yeah would you have a big oh yeah I
don't know I feel like genetics don't
play important yeah for me I'm Spanish
and Mexican so my dad and my mom said
family they're all pretty much like that
so I feel it does play a big part and my
dad is actually the one that I get my
butt genetics from so when I work out
obviously glutes are important but I
don't have to work as hard just because
I have that genetics there yeah I get to
I always had kind of like a little bit
of a big butt but like it definitely was
nowhere near like how it is now yeah
like I'm very transparent with that on
well you guys don't have me on Instagram
but like with my clients that's what I
promote am I growing a big butt growing
a big book I'm all for like any kind of
body modifications as long as people
aren't like
harming themselves for sure because I
know like body image like in our society
is just like hips ass tits whatever and
people can like really get down on
themselves about that if they don't have
that so I know people go through like
crazy length just to like have that
ideal body but I mean as long as people
are being safe and like I don't mind at
all for me it just depends like I don't
think there's anything wrong with it I'm
all for like you know if you want to get
it get it but as someone who knows it's
possible to grow a butt in the gym I'm
like just try try before you pay the
money try before you almost could kill
yourself you know like you could die the
rest are really high I feel like it's
important for people to First Look Into
the wrist look into like how does it
work how might it affect your body like
down the line before jumping to it just
because it's a trending thing you know
you have to be careful of like if you
get the surgery those other insecurities
might pop up and there might be
something else so you just have to make
sure it's something that you generally
want not that you think it's going to
solve all your problems I agree yeah
I'm curious
[Music]
sorry
sorry babe okay I think they voted me
out because of my wardrobe but not only
that I have social anxiety so what I
think it like made me suspicious if you
think the mole is still a money five and
you want to keep playing I'll have you
raise your hand on the count of three
one two three
wow
okay I don't know if we should like just
move like move ourselves like watch it
move I'm not trying to be weird but like
we touched it but like I feel like
visually you know okay okay
I'll go first okay I don't know what do
you guys wanted to join
all right
yeah it's true it's hard it is hard I
feel like when I walk like it just moves
so like I don't know like something like
that something like that I have no
reason
I don't know
I'm really scared so you are yeah it's
true
Joy's outfit it was super hard to tell
and I was like why are you trying to
hide something you know you guys think
that people are generally more attracted
to bigger butts today today yeah it's so
boom everywhere on my freaking Instagram
everywhere I drive down the road like I
feel like it's just in your face Kim
Kylie Jenner in the black community like
ass is just like always just been a
thing because like genetically that's
just how it is and I feel like things
that black people do or like things that
black people have like features become
Trends so I do feel like it's trendy
right now because like beforehand black
people used to get made fun of like in
menstrual shows like for having like
bigger assets oh yeah that's true but I
think it'll die out like every yeah it's
boobs or butt and then it's being tiny
like remember everyone was skinny and
then it was like the thigh gaps and
everything yeah and it's just it's a
fluctuating thing I also think it's
different in different societies
really like encouraged to have a big but
I think it's more of that like slim
frame but in the U.S for sure it's like
the slim thick look right now yes yeah
no it is whenever I order off like yes
style or like nothing anything like that
yeah yeah
foreign
my suspicions have grown
[Music]
I'm slipped between two people there was
actually a tie Naya and joy so these two
people have 30 seconds to back up their
butt and prove them
yeah when I was older I mean older when
I was younger I always like you said
I've always had how do you say like I've
just always had a bigger bottom and my
thighs and I've definitely like I don't
know I really don't know how else to say
but like I was pretty much just genetics
like I would never get anything done
besides like my lips done
so I spend about like 10 hours every
week in the gym I naturally have a big
butt but I do two days of glutes with
quads and hamstrings and everything like
that and like I said earlier my dad's
the one that I get my butt genetics from
not my mom he used to like tear his
pants sitting down that's never happened
to me is there
it's hard to find like pants skirts
dresses that fit
ah
I don't know I feel like At first I
thought maybe we already got the mole
out but then I was like maybe they just
didn't know who to pick so if you think
the bowl is still among the four of you
raise your hand on the count three to
keep playing one two three
oh my God I want to but it's okay all
right if the Box turns green you guys
have successfully voted the mole out and
you all get to split the cash prize if
the Box turns red that means you guys
have lost and the mole has won are you
ready no I know
oh my God
amazing amazing amazing
the bowl can reveal themselves okay
you guys ready yes
one two three
I actually got a bvl when I was 17 about
to turn 18. do you think a BBL spread
body positivity no that's really
controversial for me to say but I just
feel like social media makes it seem
like you have to have like an hourglass
figure you have to have a big butt I
chose to get a bbo because I was really
um self-conscious about the way that I
looked and I just genuinely felt like
having a BBL it would just improve my
quality of life
[Music]
nothing else
oh
[Music]